وين احييكم مشاهدينا من جديد قبل اي من
قليله اعلنت سلطات وجمارك مطار القاهره
احاله الممثله المصريه من الشلبي الى
نيابه العامه بعد توقيفها للاشتباه بوجود
موده مخدره بحوزتها وبحسب المصادر كانت
الممثله المصريه عائده طائره من الولايات
المتحده ومعها مواد جيش تبع في كونها
مخدرات قبل ان يتم التحفظ عليها رائحه
حالتها فيما بعد اذن نيابه العامه لاتخاذ
الاجراءات المناسبه وبعد ساعات امره
باخلاء سبيل الفنانه منه شلبي بضمان
الماليه بعد انكارها حيازه واحراز المواد
بتهمه التعاطي كما امرت نيابه بارسال
المواد المخدره لمصلحه الطب الشرعيه
طبيعتها هذا وتما تداول بعض الصور التي
قيل انها للمواد التي عثر عليها وعثرت
عليها الجمارك المصريه كما تم نشره صوره
لجوازي س فيها دون اخفاء بياناتها الشخصيه
الامر الذي اثار حفيظه الكثيرين على وسائل
التواصل
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من القاهره
نقد الفني طارق الشناوي من القاهره كذلك
المحامي وليد زهران اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام
نحن امام ملف الواقع اثار جدلا كبيرا في
الاوصاف الفنيه الصحفيه والجماهيريه لاننا
نتحدث عن فنانه معروفه محبوبه جدا متابعه
همم
والبعض في الحقيقه سابدا معك استاذ طارق
همم لم يفهم موضوع
استباحه او استشهاد التشهير بالمشاهير او
عرض وثائقهم الشخصيه او عرض تفاصيل القضيه
على الراي العام حضرتك من الذين يعني هل
ترى بان هذا مباح هذا ممكن او هناك حدود
تمنع ذلك
استاذ طارق
لا تمنح الفنان درعا واقيا ضد المساله
القانونيه فانها كمان ينبغي الا تكون
سلاحا للطعن في شرفه في سمعته في اسمه في
عائلته فبالتالي المشكله في في تداول
الاحراز اللي همم انها اللي كانت منسوبه
للجمارك انها اصبحت ماده بما فيها جواز
السفر ماده في كل ال- همم المواقع الصحفيه
على كثرتها وكانه تشهير بها لكن لكن كونك
تشك الفنان فان انسان عموما يطلع بقى فنان
او مش فنان مغمور او مشهور ما فيهاش حاجه
انك تفتش او رجال الجمارك عندما يشاورهم
بعد الشك ويكرروا تفتيش حقيبه اي انسان
يجب ان احنا نعتبر ان هذه هي العداله انه
لم تحمي شهرته ولا وظيفته ولا اي شيء اخر
غير ان هم عندهم شيء من الشك لغايه هنا ده
مطلوب ولكن بعد ذلك هو التجاوز وهو ان ان
ان تحال هذه صور لمثل هذه الاشياء الى
الراي العام عموما وبعدين نبتدي التفسير
انها مواد مخدره في حين ان النيابه يعني
كان قرارها عادل جدا ومنطقي يجتبه ما فيش
يقين ما هو ممكن يكتب على حاجه شيكولاته
مش شبه انها شيكولاته وممكن بتاع
الشيكولاته يعني في الحالتين كلمه لشيء
سلبي او ايجابي المفروض
بس ده الجانب اللي انا اختلفت فيه لكن انه
فنان يرتكب جريمه او جنايه او اي شيء يجب
ان يعاقب اذا ثبت انه ارتكب هذه الجريمه
لان هو فنان قوي لانه
وضحت الفكره
استاذ وليد القاعده همم تقول المتهم بريء
حتى تثبت اذانته ولكن في واقع الحال وفي
الملفات الاخيره التي نتبعها من مصر او من
خارج مصر وكان المتهم همم مدان حتى يثبت
همم برائته همم
فهل هذه المقوله صارت تخص المشاهير واا
يجب ان يدافعوا عن انفسهم فقط لانهم تحت
المجهر تحت الاضواء
انا باحييك على استخدام جمله همم المتهم
بريء حتى تضبط ابنته ولكن الواقع هو العكس
انه المتهم ودان حتى تزبط براءته وده
الواقع الفعلي في المجتمع لان المجتمع
بيصدر احكامه قبل احكام القضاء مبدايا ان
حب نبرا سياحه يعني صحه النيابه العامه من
التحيات ان هي اخر سبيل الفنانه بضمان
مالي وهمم والناس طبعا على مواقع الاتصال
الاجتماعي بكل طوائف بكل الافكار بكل
ثقافات اعتقدوا ان هناك تحيز لل- للفنانه
او ان هي عاصمه مشهوره بيتموا معاملتها
معامله اخرى ولكن النيابه استخدمت كافه
سلطاتها في اخلاق سبيل المتهمه لان طبعا
الكميه المضبوطه طالما مع الواقع التعاطي
ومنتهى من التعاطي عامه بيتم اخلاء سبيله
في المجمل اما بضمان محل الاقامه او بضمان
مالي لان القضيه ما قال تحقيق والعينات
والمضبوطه بيتم ارسالها الى المعمل
الجنائي لك فحصها ما يمكن ترجع العينات ان
هي مش مش مخدرات فبالتالي الانسان
ولكن الاستاذ وليد همم قبل حتى ان تصل هذه
العينه للمختبر همم كان هناك نشر لوثائق
من شلبي الشخصيه وكان هناك نشر من داخل
مقر المطار ل همم ما تم همم العثور عليه
من يتحمل مسؤوليه اخراج هذه الصور ونشرها
فيما بعد
اولا طبعا الواقع ازازه اي الوقائع
الصحافه الصحافه بتنشر طالما المصدر صريح
ومعلوم اللي هو محضر شرطه هيبقى احنا مش
قدام واقع التشهير باحد الاشخاص المصدر
حتى الصحفي لما بيتحرى عنه ده مصدره ومحضر
شرطه ما قلناش ان في حد قدم بلاغ ضد
الفنانه بيتيمها بشيء بيقطعينها بشرفها او
بيصبها او في نوع من التاشيره ولكن المصدر
محضر شرطه بناء عليه اللي نشر نشر بناء
على محضر شرطه يبقى مشهرش اما نقطه اللي
هو تسريب الاوراق او تسريب صوره يعني احنا
هو اللي سال بس في تسريب صوره جواز سفرها
ده اللي سال فيه انه طلع صوره جواز السفر
صوره وثائق شخصيه تخصها اما المضبوطات
عامه في اجراءات الضبط لازم بتصور يعني
الضغط لازم تتصور الاشياء المضبوطه امامي
حاليا لازم تتصور في تم تلاعب بالاحراز
احنا دلوقت قدامه
الحبس المشدده ولكن نحن لا نعلم نسال فقط
يعني المفروض بانه يتم تصوير هل الاحتفاظ
بها حتى تكون موجوده كوثائق للتحقيق همم
وليس لنشرها وضيف يقول سيد طارق كيف يقول
بانه من نشر هو نشر طبقا لمحضر شرطه وهذا
يخوله النشر همم الى اي مدى هناك حدود
نتحدث عنها ام لا حدود صحفيه لناشر مثل
هكذا معطيات
في خطا اساسا من الجهه اللي سربت الصور
عموما اي صحفي في الدنيا وانا طبعا اساسا
صحفي دي اسعى وراء الحقيقه واسعه وراء
الوثيقه كمان في نفس الوقت لكن مثل هذه
الاوراق او صور او الوثائق ينبغي ان تظل
في طي الكتمان هي ليست للنشر يعني حتى
التصوير لا ده جزء من عمل رجال الجمارك
يصوروا ال- ال- الاحراز عشان يظل الامر ده
في يديهم لكن انها تخرج من هذا المكان الى
الواقع الافتراضي والصور والمواقع لا احنا
هناك خطا ويجب التحقيق مع من سمح بتداول
هذه الصور
عادي وهذا دارج وهذا ما يجب ان يكون صحيح
ولكن خلي
ترسل للاجهزه
للمواقع هناك ده يعتبر اعتداء هنا خطا
يعني في خطا يعني وسط بطريقه او باخرى مش
شرط يكون رجال جمارك هما اللي سرقوها ولكن
وصلت بطريقه
لضيفي سؤال استاذ وليد تفضل
ان احنا شوفنا في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وفي الجرائد عامه الاف الجرائم واشخاص
بيتم نشر صورهم وارقام بطاريهم وصور
بطاريهم همم يعني في النقطه دي تحديدا هل
حضرتك همم بتقصد ان هي عشان فنانه ومشهوره
ما يتعملش معها زي ما اتعمل مع عامه الشعب
كلهم معامله الشعب كل ما بن جريمه صور
وبتنزل على التواصل الاجتماعي قبل ما
الشرطه ما تقبض عليه
نمره اثنين
الخطا لا يبرر الخطا
تفضل استاذ طارق
في جرائد ومواقع لا تزال لما يكون في واحد
متهم ما بتنشرش عينيه بتحط عمامه سوداء
غمامه سوداء على عينيه حتى لا يراه الناس
وبيتعمده ما يقولوش اسمه هنا دي دي
القواعد الصحفيه تم اختراقها خطا لكن مش
معنى كده ان انا باحمي المشهور لا انا
باحمي اي انسان مغمور او مشهور يطبق عليه
نفس المعايير دي اخطاء صحفيه ان تنشر همم
صوره متهم باقول مش مدان
وكل تم هذا الخطا مع اشخاص عاديين ده ده
احم الانسان العادي
لو سمحت
في كلمه
احنا وجدنا وجدنا تعاطف مع الفنانه لانها
فنانه على الرغم ان مع سلامه الاجراءات
سيضبط ادانتها مع سلامه الاجراءات وانا
بخمنش يقول مع سلامه الاجراءات سيظبط
ادانتها بتهمه حيازه المواد المخدره
حتى لا نتحدث عن تكهنات سننتظر ونناقش كل
ذلك
شكرا جزيلا لكم السلام عليكم